We have developed speed,
but we have shut ourselves machinery that gives abundance,
has left us in one of our knowledge,
has made us cynical,
our cleverness,
hard and unkind.
We think too much and few to little more than machinery.
We need humanity more than cleverness.
We need kindness and gentleness.
Without these qualities,
life will be violent and all will be lost.
How was never?
My parents got so mad.
It said study for school.
I don't give a fuck about.
Don't try to grade me.
Don't tell me that.
Go Study Shit.
I have my own dreams.
Oh my own mind.
Online bitch tried to take me off line.
I got Sam trying to make my own way in this world,
trying to make it,
give liberation a world so lonely.
This just me wanting only real friends is hard.
So many phones,
it's all good.
I'm moving a panel with sub life is a marathon.
I've run til I throw up raised in Houston but moved up to Nyc to join that ivy
universities.
Damn right.
I would dazed and confused.
I refuse to lose.
I had nothing to choose,
but then down to lab for robots and that Shit had my name on do not despair and
misery that is now upon us is,
but the passing of greed,
the bitterness of men who fear the way of human progress,
the heat of the men will pass and dictators day and the power they took from the
people were returned to the people.
And so long as men die,
liberty will never perish.
It was help till the crack of dawn trying to find all the buckets in my mind,
trying to reach it online.
Then I'll walk straight up to professor.
Hey y'all,
can I work in your lab?
Sure.
And we hope you stay with words were sweet to mine.
Your assigned job,
starting playing with motors and gears.
No fear.
How would lead engineer revolution was here?
So visionary,
I made a robot start up trying to make a robot.
So hot toast,
then a coal,
clean your dish a whole lot but didn't work.
We felt a whole lot.
Ah,
no money,
no sales.
I lost.
The Passion was lost,
taken by Jack Frost.
No longer the boss.
Robotics was lost.
I've packed my bags.
I left for the West.
Maybe I could find purpose again.
I didn't fucking know
you.
The people have the power,
the power to create machines,
the power to create happiness.
You the people have the power to make this life free and beautiful to make this
life a wonderful adventure.
Then in the name of democracy,
there's a shoes.
That car
shout out to SF.
My new home city.
Fucking love this place,
man.
It's so very pretty.
Ahmed's dichotomy.
Surat geology.
I guess I learned robots with sale.
Hotson me,
I'd be machine learned in neuro.
Ooh,
go.
No alphabet.
All that shit rolled is in flames.
We got to make shit better.
It makes them robots do some real shit that matters.
I'm tired of all the pain
all day.
All the lies,
all the wars,
all his by trying to make shit blow up for miles.
Kind of make us wild.
Back to the Ribbon Nile.
We got to put brains in the robots.
Make them so smart.
So Hi Vic.
Shit.
A whole lot.
Then we've free to do a whole lot.
Yeah.
Hey,
I think we can do it.
Don't you?